it has been a turbulent few years for
our educators this has led to hundreds
of vacancies and retirements so today in
fact more than 140 retiring teachers
were honored for their commitment to
education as kate houston reports
they're encouraging current teachers as
they work through issues highlighted by
the pandemic
i love teaching
and i just knew that when it was time
for me to have another adventure i would
know connie mcfarland is closing out a
storied career spanning 50 years in
education she received the lifetime
achievement award from her peers i had
many many different kinds of
environments of different ages of
students of different kinds of jobs
so that there was always a sense of
newness of excitement there were 621
retirements within ccsd in the last
school year mcfarland says expectations
of teachers has changed and they're
dealing with more responsibilities than
ever before
we have to keep the community aware of
what is needed more money is needed
smaller classes is needed national
teacher of the year juliana orta bay was
on hand to thank the retirees without
the teachers holding classrooms together
giving kids normalcy dependability
routine and instruction and that love
where would we be orta bay says she's
committed to advocating for teachers and
ensure that they get what they need to
thrive things like great health care
equitable pay for our expertise all
those things are in the making and i'm
really hopeful that they're coming kate
houston live local now right now there
are 859 teacher vacancies that number a
bit higher than normal due to count day
ccsd says that number will fluctuate
over the next month as they move
positions around all based on enrollment